So, March the 13th, 1912. This is volume 11. The baptism of the victim is a baptism of
fire and has effects superior to the baptism of water. Now, what Jesus is going to be talking
about here doesn't apply to you and me. It's for victim souls. Is that okay? So, Jesus
said, "My daughter, the baptism at birth is by water and therefore it has the power
of purifying but of not removing tendencies and passions." Now, the way that's normally
expressed in the church is that it doesn't remove concupuses. Yeah. So, you still have
the problems with the world, the flesh and the devil. That okay. On the other hand, the
baptism of the victim soul, you'd have to put in the word soul there because, unfortunately,
we have a different meaning for victim nowadays. The victim soul is a baptism of fire. Therefore,
it is not only the power of purifying but of consuming any passion or evil tendency. In
other words, it removes concupuses, which is an amazing gift because you'll never hear
Louisa talking about having problems with the world, the flesh or the devil, will you?
No. She just had a battle with the demons at the beginning to show her how to do the
battling. Even more, Jesus said, "I myself baptize the soul bit by bit." Now, as you
know, he does everything bit by bit with us because we couldn't take it any other way.
My thought baptizes the thought of the soul. My heart beat baptizes her heartbeat. My desire,
her desire and so on. However, this baptism is carried out between myself and the soul
according to whether she gives herself to me without ever taking it back. Now, that's
the bit you need to underline because it's quite easy to say yes today and then sort
of make compromises a few days later without ever taking back what she's given to me. So
this is why, my daughter, you do not feel the evil tendencies and the like. Now, there's
Louisa that concupuses and has been removed from her an incredible gift. It comes from
your state of victim's soul. You need to add in the word soul again. And I tell you this
for your consolation. So tell Father G to be well attentive for this is the mission of
missions, the apostolate of apostolates. I want him always with me and all intent within
me. Okay. So, March the 15th, 1912, the divine will is the sanctity of sanctities. The souls
who live in the divine will are true living hosts. This is a wonderful teaching now. So
Louisa says she continues in her usual state. So Jesus said, my daughter, my will is the
sanctity of sanctities because the divine will is the essence of God. It has to be the
sanctity of sanctities. The soul who does my will, that means lives in my will. However,
small, ignorant and unknown, leaves the other saints behind in spite of their prejudice,
sensational conversions and miracles. Now, many people find that difficult to understand.
But if I am a small person in a satellite going to the moon, I am traveling in a much
more exalted way than anybody who is traveling to England in any form of transport you can
get. That makes sense? Because I'm in a superior flight. It's as simple as that. And I'm going
to a superior goal. That's what he's saying. So no matter how small and apparently unimportant
you are to yourself or to anybody else, the living in the divine will is the sanctity
of sanctities and therefore does in fact surpass all the, the prejudice, sensational conversions
and miracles of the past. Isn't that incredible? Rather, in comparison, the souls who do my
will are queens. That's the song of songs, chapter 6 verse 8. And it is as if all others
were at their service. Look at the difference in the status of the two. It seems that the
souls who do my will do nothing because it's completely interior mission while they actually
do everything because being in my will, they act in a divine manner in a hidden and surprising
way. So they are the light that illuminates. They are the winds that purify. They are the
fire that burns. They are miracles that make others do miracles. Notice they are miracles.
Because to live like this is miraculous. Those who do miracles are channels. But in these
souls, that's those who live in the divine will resides the power behind those miracles.
Isn't that something else? Therefore, people who live in the divine will are the foot of
the missionary, the tongue of the preachers, the strength of the weak, the patience of
the sick, the rule of the superiors, the obedience of the subjects, the tolerance of
the slandered, the firmness in dangers, the heroism of the heroes, the courage of the
martyrs, the sanctity of the saints, and so with all the rest. I'd love to know what
all the rest are, wouldn't you? Being in my will, they concur with all the good that
can exist both in heaven and on earth, that is the operative statement there. And the rest
of it is simply illustrating it. Is that okay? Because being in the divine will, you concur
with whatever God is doing, no matter what he's doing or where he's doing it. This is
why I can surely say that these souls are my true hosts but living hosts, not dead ones.
Now, what is it about the little wafer that you and I receive as communion? It carries
the actual presence of God. And if it didn't carry the actual presence of God, we wouldn't
call it holy communion. We wouldn't call it a sacred host, would we? So what Jesus is
saying here is that people who live in the divine will are his true hosts. That means
he is actually living within us. That's what you have to take on board. He is actually
living within us and therefore he can work through us. He can look at someone through
your eyes. He can speak to someone through your lips. He can approach somebody through
your feet. He can help somebody through your hands and so on and so forth. He can love
someone through your heart. They are my true hosts but living ones, not dead ones. In fact,
the accidents that form the host are not full of life. That means the bread or the wine.
They're not full of life nor do they influence my life but the soul is full of life and by
doing my will that's living in the divine will. She influences and concurs with all
that I do. So this is something you've got to read over and over again and ask the Lord
to enable you to absorb it. This is why these hosts consecrated to my will. Now, there is
at prayer of consecration to the divine will but you can say a prayer of consecration and
not be consecrated to the divine will. Have I confused you? Okay. Because consecration
means I actually hand myself over completely and I can say the words of a most beautiful
prayer and I may not have interiorly handed myself over. I may not have this wonderful
prayer in my possession. I may not even know it's written but I may hand myself over to
the Lord and I'm consecrated to him. That's like saying a husband and wife actually become
one by handing themselves over to each other. It's not just something you write on paper.
It's not just something you celebrate in a church. You actually do the action of giving
to the other. I'm making sense, aren't I? Okay. That's what he's talking about. That's
what consecration is that we actually give ourselves to him. And whether you do that
with the wonderful words that Louisa has given to us or whether you do them with your own
awkward stuttering words doesn't actually make any difference. What matters is that you do
it. Is that okay? And mean it. Yeah. That you actually do it and you mean it. So the soul
is full of life. And in doing or living in my will, she influences and concurs with
all that I do. This is why these hosts consecrated by my will are more dear to me than the very
sacramental hosts. Why? Because the sacramental hosts can't give him any response. And if
I have reason to exist in the sacramental hosts, it is to form the sacramental hosts
of my will. So in other words, one consecration is a step to the other. Okay. My daughter,
he said, I take such delight in my will that in simply hearing one speak about it, I feel
overjoyed. So he's overjoyed at this class. Because we're actually speaking about it.
And I call the whole of heaven to make feast. You didn't think that heaven was celebrating
every time you came here, did you? Imagine, he said, yourself, what will become of these
souls who will actually do it? That's who will actually live in it as distinct from
reading about it. In them, I find all the contentment. And to them, I give all the contentment.
Your life is the life of the blessed in heaven. You're already living the life that the blessed
in heaven are living. The only difference is that on earth, you also have suffering and
purification. Whereas in heaven, their suffering and purification is finished. Two things only
do they cherish, desire and yearn, my will and love. Now, would you ever take your pen
and put a ring around those words? Because I've told you many times that divine will
and love is the summary of the 36 volumes, divine will and love. So even if you never
had an opportunity to read the whole of the 36 volumes, once you try as best you can to
live in the divine will and to love with Jesus' love, you are actually fulfilling what is
being said in these volumes. Does that make sense to you? Okay. So all they want is my
will and love. They have little to do while in fact they do everything. The virtues themselves
remain absorbed in my will and in love. And so they have nothing to do with them anymore.
Since my will contains, possesses and absorbs everything, but in a way which is divine, immense
and endless, this is the life of the blessed. Tony Hickey calls that infinite perfect and
eternal. That's his great expression, isn't it? Yeah. Okay. So even the virtues that you
have been living, they're all taken up into the divine will and into love. And therefore
they're all transformed and they operate at a much higher plane. Now that needs a good
bit of thought put into it. So let's go to March the 20th, 1912. Everything is in giving
oneself to Jesus. Now notice the little word everything. I like ringing particular words
that are just absolutely essential to the whole thing. Everything is in giving oneself
to Jesus. You see, you could study all of this stuff. You could give lectures on it.
But if you haven't given yourself to Jesus, you're outside of it. And you're in the position
then at St. Paul said that having taught others I could be lost myself. I remember
that quite frequently. And so I'm not going to do finding myself in my usual state. I'm
just going to give the message. Is that okay? Jesus said my daughter, they, that's the priests,
do not want to understand that everything is in giving oneself completely. Now the completely
is a hundred percent to me. And in doing my will always and in everything. Now that's
living in the divine will. So what Jesus saying there is the whole thing hinges on us giving
ourselves completely to the Lord and on living in the divine will always. You see, you'll
hear me saying, I'm going to speak in drum and team, that I have a problem with Louisa's
writings that everybody would say. She's been teaching since 2011. How can she have a
problem with Louisa's writings? The problem is that in volume one, Louisa had three spiritual
marriages. Three. And the whole 35 volumes that sit on volume one sits on the fact that
the person who experiences this has had three spiritual marriages. Now don't put your hands
up if you've had three. Don't even put your hands up if you've had two. Do you see we're
in a different situation altogether, to her. And so all of these explanations are to try
and get us on board. Because we haven't had her experience and even worse than that we're
not victim souls either. So we're coming at this with frightful disadvantage. So we just
need to be understanding and patient with ourselves. And if you find, Oh God, I didn't
think of that for a few days. It's all right. Just start now. It's okay. Because we're not
where she was. Okay. And so we have to understand, you see union with God is giving yourself
completely to him and living in his divine will. That's what it is. So here we are and
it's volume 11. And after all the instruction we've got, here we are hearing something completely
basic again. And Jesus says, once I have obtained this, I myself keep pushing the souls. In other
words, if you get somebody that far, he's like the teacher who knows that this kid can
do well in the leaving certificate and then starts pushing. Am I right? Am I right? Start
pushing them to try and achieve what they're actually capable of doing. And so I keep pushing
the souls saying to each one of them, my daughter, take this enjoyment, discomfort, this relief,
this refreshment. This is the difference. If they had taken those things before giving
themselves completely to me and doing my will always and in everything, these would have
been human things. You see, before you give yourself completely to the Lord, the problem
is we're doing too much on the human level. He says, give yourself completely to me and
I will give you everything you need but on a higher level. It's not that he wants to
strip you of everything, it's that he wants to give you things on a much higher plane
and the spiritual and the human don't mix. And he said, and afterwards, they are divine.
So the divine and the human don't mix. And that's why you'll hear as we go on in the
writings, the dangers of the human will, a falling back, you know, there's a very interesting
text in Revelation 12 where we're told that the tale of the dragon pulled one-third of
the stars from the sky to the earth. Okay. Now there are at least three or four levels
of interpretation of that. I just want to give you one. And that is, the devil wants
to pull every one of us down from the spiritual level, that's heaven, down to the human level
which is earth. Because we have lost everything that was offered to us in the divine will.
So I'm just giving you an interpretation of that for divine will people. Is that okay?
Because the amazing thing about scripture is when you interpret it according to a particular
group, it's amazing how it fits. It's just something that struck me recently. To pull
us down from the spiritual to the human. You see, this human was where we started and
there's no point falling off the mountain now that you've climbed it. You know what I mean?
I saw that the other day when we were climbing that mountain. It was hard enough to get up.
You wouldn't want to fall back, you know. And Jesus said, and since these are my things,
I no longer feel jealous and I say to myself, if she takes a licit pleasure, she takes it
because I want it. Isn't that interesting? And if she deals with people, if she converses
licitly, it's because I want it. And if I didn't want it, she'd be ready to stop. It's
not interesting because you see, you're committed to his will. Therefore, I put things at her
disposal because everything she does is the effect of my will no longer of her own.
Okay, so on the way to experiencing that and its fullness, it's good to say to the Lord,
I only want it if you want it. I like this or I would really like to have that or whatever,
but I only want it if you want it. And what you've done is you've shifted the plane just
from the purely human to the divine to let the Lord take over. Okay, tell me, oh, my daughter,
what have you lacked since you gave yourself completely to me? I've given you my tastes,
in other words, my own desires. They usually use the word tastes for desires, my pleasures
and all of myself for your contentment. This in the supernatural order, but in the natural
order also, I've not allowed you to lack anything, confessors, communions and all the
rest. Now she was in a bed, so she didn't need all the June I need. Rather, since you
wanted me alone, you did not want the confessors so often, but wanting everything in abundance
for one who wanted to deprive herself of everything for me, I didn't listen to you. So in other
words, he supplies all her needs. Now people who are living at that level say that the
Lord does in fact want to supply all your needs. And the word is A double L. We spend
our times worrying about why we can't supply them, and we don't trust him enough to let
him do it. Don't for what pain I feel in my heart in seeing that souls do not want to
understand this, even those who are said to be most good. So my comment there is from
Trisavavola, Saint Trisavavola, God alone sufficed. Now we certainly saw that with Mary
of Magdalene in Saint-Bohm, she chose God alone. So April the 4th 1912, the divine will
must be the center of everything because the divine will is the center of the blessed trinity.
The blessed trinity is the center of everything that exists. Therefore, naturally, the divine
will must be the center of our lives. That's just logical. So Jesus said, my daughter,
my will is the center. The other virtues are the circumference. Now from here on in you
will find him using the wheel often enough. If you just draw a wheel and spokes, you know
what he's talking about here. Just put a little wheel and spokes right beside it, and
you know what he's talking about. My will is the center, and the virtues are the circumference.
He's going to use that image many times. Imagine a wheel in whose middle all the rays
are centered. What would happen if one of these rays wanted to detach itself from the
center? First, the ray would make a bad impression, that's sure. Second, it would remain inoperative
because no longer being attached to the center, it would no longer receive life, and it would
be dead. And the wheel in moving would actually get rid of it so the spoke would fall off.
Such is my will for the soul. My will is the center. All the things which are not done in
my will, and only to fulfill my volition, even if they're holy things, virtues, or good works,
these are like rays detached from the center of the wheel. They are works and virtues without
life. That actually requires a good deal of thinking. It's all right to read the words
on the page, but I have to look at my life and say to myself, "Anything in my day which
is not done in the divine will, even if it's something holy, something that I consider
religious." Okay, I'm not going to give any examples for fear anybody would quote me.
Even if I consider them virtuous or good works, he says, "If they're not done in the divine
will, they're useless because the divine will is the center of everything." So the thing
we've got to connect all the time is connect into the divine will. Yeah, fuse all the time.
And even if you forget the word fuse, you've got to keep on saying with your divine will
or in your divine will or something. You've got to say you're connecting so that this
is actually happening because it's important that he includes even holy things. And like
the rays detached from the center of the wheel, they would be useless. They are works and
virtues without life. That's a waste of time, isn't it? They would never please me. Now,
that's the bit you underline. If you're trying to live in the divine will and you're doing
something that's not attached to his divine will, he said it won't please him naturally
enough. Rather, I would do everything to get rid of them and to punish them. That's the
bit that shocked me. So I just put exclamation marks after that in my book and said, "En
be, why would you punish them? Just think of yourself taking a child, young child, maybe
down the town to do something. And the child is not connecting with you. You're the one
that knows the safety of the journey. You know the dangers of the road. You know where
you have to go. You know what has to be achieved. And the child is pulling away from you all
the time. You will tug at that child, won't you? And you will speak to that child and say,
this is what we have to do. So I don't think and punish them means divine judgment. I think
it means correction. That's why I gave you that example. So April the 10th, 1912, trusting
souls are the outpouring and enjoyment of the love of Jesus. I always change the word
amusement. We don't use it in the way it's being used here. But you can say that a parent
can enjoy their children, isn't that right? So the big lesson here is trust and confidence.
Now this is terribly important because St. Therese of Lesus said, you will get exactly
out of God the amount that you trust him for. But think of yourself again with small children.
And the child that can get most out of you is the one who really trusts you and has total
countries and tells you you're the greatest daddy that ever lived or your greatest mummy
who ever lived. And the child who has this enormous trust in you can, in fact, get a much
better response out of you. So this is a normal part of relationship. So Jesus said, my daughter,
the souls who will shine the most. Now that's Daniel 12, 3. Book of Daniel, shine like stars.
He says, Daniel 12, 3. The souls who will shine the most like bright gems in the crown
of my mercy are the souls who have more trust. Now notice the crown of my mercy. He doesn't
say the crown of my wisdom, the crown of my justice, the crown of anything else, the
crown of my mercy. The thing we need most from God, as you know, is mercy. And the meaning
of mercy is love given to somebody who doesn't deserve it. They're the souls who have more
trust because the more trust they have, the more they give space for the attribute of
my mercy to pour into them any grace they want. Now if you want very good reflections
on this, just read St. Faustina. She's talking about that all the time, isn't she? Yeah.
And what was her prayer? Wasn't it Jesus I trust in you? Yeah, I trust in you. And so
this is the same type of message. And it's given in 1912, so it's given approximately
around the same time that Jesus is giving the messages to Faustina. It's not the exact
time, but you know, around the same time, from the same person, on the same issue. So
of course it's the same. And it's just important for us to know that the Lord was speaking to
other people besides Louisa during these years. So the more you trust, the more you'll get
any grace you want. I like the any grace you want, but do you? Yeah, well, he's, well,
I have heard me say this before that the Lord has told me to tell everybody I'm in contact
with that he wants us to trust him beyond reason. Okay. So on the other hand, the soul
who does not have true trust or self closes the graces within me. In other words, you
prevent the grace from coming, remaining always poor and unequipped while my love remains
constrained within me. And I suffer very much. And in order not to suffer so much and to
be able to pour out my love more freely, I deal more with those souls who trust than
with others. Okay. Proverbs 831, the Lord delights to be with the children of men. There's lots
of of Sam's that deal with trust as well. Proverbs 831. So with the soul that trust me
the most with these, I can pour out my love, I can play. That's not our image of God, is
it? And yet it comes up quite frequently in Louisa. And also that Proverbs 831, the Lord
delights that he's, the text goes on to say, he's ever at play. That's not our image of
God. We were given a very distorted image of God that I can play. I can cause loving
contrasts since there's no worry that they might take offense or become fearful on the
country. They become more brave and they take everything in order to love me more. Now the
way I would translate that into our language is to say be yourself because one of the things
is very notable in these writings is Louisa really is herself in responding to the Lord.
Therefore trusting souls are the outpouring and the enjoyment of my love, the ones who
receive more graces and are the richest. So that's a very important one. Okay. So April
the 20th, 1912. How nature itself tends towards happiness and the difference between human
desires and divine desires that the world is tastes here. Jesus said, my daughter, nature
tends towards happiness with an irresistible force because we were made by God for eternal
happiness. But with reason because it was made to be happy and of a divine and eternal
happiness. Now your Pentecatechism told you that if you're old enough, okay, we were
made to know love and serve him on earth and be happy with him forever. So that's this
move that's in the human race. But to their own great harm, some get attached to one taste,
some to two, some to three, some to four. And the rest of their nature remains either empty
or without taste, embittered, annoyed and nauseated. So you can, instead of moving towards happiness,
you can get hooked on alcohol, drugs, sex, power, money, whatever it is. And you can
actually destroy yourself. In fact, human tastes, even holy ones are mixed with a little bit
of human. Now you see the human and the divine don't mix. One has to give way to the other.
And that's the very thing that happens in debt that we leave the human behind and only
the divine part of us goes on. In human taste, even holy ones, they're mixed with a little
bit of human. They do not have the strength to absorb the whole of one's nature and to
overwhelm it completely in the taste. More so, since I keep embittering these tastes so
as to be able to give the creature all my tastes, which being innumerable have the strength
to absorb the whole of our nature in our taste. That's the way it is stated there is a little
bit awkward. Notice that the Lord says I keep embittering these tastes. What he's saying
is I don't let you find total happiness in sex, power, money or whatever it is. I make
sure that you experience that the disillusionment of this stuff and the disillusionment of this
stuff will make you turn back to the true source. And can anyone give greater love than this
that in order to give the greatest, I take away the little and in order to give the all
I take away the nothing. Now, you started doing that with children at a very early stage
when you took a knife out of the little hand and you put a tie back in. You took the thing
that would hurt and you gave back the thing that they could actually enjoy. You took something
dangerous that the child had picked off the table or whatever else that was going to harm
them and you put into the little hand something that would help them. So, the Lord says he
does this with us all the time. And notice the little thing is the human thing and the
great thing is the divine thing. In order to give all I take away the nothing because
you see the place we're supposed to be all the time is in our nothingness. I call it
the safe place. And so the nothings that we cling to, money, sex, power, whatever it
is, alcohol, drugs, whatever it is that we cling to. They're absolute nothings you can't
take them with you. And you'll hear me talking in Dromantine that they'll be under the list
of prohibited baggage because I'll be talking about us taking an aeroplane flight to heaven
and the prohibited baggage list is very long. The baggage allowance is very little and as
the Lord's getting me to work I've been working on this for ages and it struck me that the
so little you can take I said Lord it's like traveling with Ryan here you only have your
pajamas and your toothbrush. You're only allowed love you see. Love, joy and peace to
take with you. But the prohibited baggage that the list is as long as a wet week. And
of course you get your scrutiny on the way St. Peter's know you can't have that. That's
not allowed up here. So what the Lord wants me to do for you in Dromantine is to translate
a lot of very special stuff into very ordinary language. So we can actually hear it. And
that not only can we hear what we can pass it on to other people as well. So he takes
away the little thing, the nothing. And yet this operating of mine is taken badly sent
by creatures yet. They clench the fist to God and how can God be a good God and do that
to me. And that's because we don't understand that he's trying to give us something greater.
Okay. Now the big surprise in the next one April 23rd 1912. How in all things Jesus proves
his love for the creature. Notice if you're going to ring something in all things good
bad and indifferent he shows his love because God is love he can't operate any other way.
And true sanctity is doing the divine will and in reordering all things in Jesus. Okay.
So Jesus said to Louis my daughter, sometimes I allow a fault in a soul who loves me in
order to class for more tightly to myself. That should be a big surprise for you because
I don't know about you. But when I was learning about holiness and everything I thought no
faults were allowed that you had to be sort of plue perfect. But that's not actually
so. One of the most famous answers to this that I got was in a book I read about St. Gertrude
the Great. You heard of Gertrude? Her self and mech tilled her sister were orphaned when
they were very young. And you're talking about the 11th century I think 10th or 11th. And
they were put into a convent the poor kids. And when they grew up they both joined the
sisters. And eventually fast forward Gertrude becomes the most famous abbess on the earth.
So much so that cardinals and bishops and abbots and everybody were consulting her for
her wisdom and so on. And one day mech tilled her sister was praying and she said to the
Lord, I don't understand this. Gertrude is famous, you know, all over the earth for being
the holiest, whatever. And all these abbots and all these important people are coming
to consult her. But they don't live with her. And so the Lord said, what's your problem?
And she said, you know, in a convent she said, we have to ask permission for everything.
That still persists in convent. And she said, you can go into our office and she could snap
at you. And then in the afternoon she's entertaining these cardinals and bishops and giving them
advice and everything. I don't get it. And that's when Jesus told her that Gertrude asked
him, he said, at least I'm exaggerating that a hundred times a day to try and deal with
her touchiness or whatever it was. And he said, I don't do it. He said, I refuse to
heal her. And mecha said, well, why would you refuse to heal her? He said, well, it
gives you an opportunity to grow in humility. It gives other people an opportunity to grow
in patience and other people an opportunity to grow in love. And she continues to grow
in humility. She's the humblest person on earth. That's what Jesus said. Find that
interesting? Yeah. We're inclined to demand that other people are perfect. Instead of
accepting a person as presented and allowing whatever that presentation does to you to
make you grow, because he has to use something. And the book of Proverbs says, iron sharpened
iron. A man is refined by contact with his neighbor. Interesting. Here's Jesus saying
it here. I allow a fault. Sometimes I allow a fault in the soul who loves me because Gertrude
loved him in order to class more tightly to myself and oblige her to do greater things
for my glory. In other words, the person is continuously stimulated to have to try and
improve. In fact, the more I give to her, permitting even faults with an S on it in order to be
moved to greater compassion for her miseries and to love her more, filling her with my
carisms. Now, there's a wrong spelling in my book. It says C H A R I S M A S. Knock out
the A carisms. The more I compel her to do great things for me. Now, notice that the
Lord is using the person's fault to make other people grow in holiness and to make the person
herself grow in holiness. We need to let God do his own business, don't we? Instead of
demanding that other people become the way I think they should be because, you see, if
I demand that you become the way I think you should be, it's going to let me off the hook,
isn't it? I won't be challenged by it. Yeah. And so if you stay the way you are, and I
stay the way I am, the Lord can use us all to help each other. So it's this grand acceptance
of the other. It's beautiful, isn't it? Because that's what love is. This is grand acceptance
of the other. My daughter, he said, my love for the soul. They keep on using the word
creature here. My love for the soul is great. Do you see how the light of the sun invades
the earth? If you could see, this is the beginning of rounds here. And he'll recognize the text
because I put them into the rounds I wrote. If you could see how many atoms, how many
atoms out of that light in those atoms of light you would hear my melodious voice. One
after the other, they would repeat to you, I love you, I love you, I love you. In such
a way as to give you no time to count them, you would remain drowned inside love. And
indeed, I love you, I love you, I love you in the light that fills your eyes. I love
you in the air that you breathe. I love you in the whistling of the wind that touches
your hearing. I love you in the warmth and in the cold felt by your touch. I love you
in the blood that flows in your veins. My heartbeat says, I love you in the beating of
your heart. I repeat to you, I love you in each thought of your mind. I love you in each
action of your hands. I love you in each step of your feet. I love you in each word because
nothing happens inside or outside of you without the concurrence of an act of my love
towards you. That's Sam 1 4 5 verse 17. Sam 1 4 5 verse 17, God only acts out of love.
So one I love you of mine does not wait for another and your I love you is how many do
you have for me. Louisa said you remain confused. She said, I felt deafened inside and out full
chorus by the I love yous of my sweet Jesus. While my I love yous were so scared, so limited
and I said, oh my lover Jesus, who can ever match you? But with what I have said, it seems
that I have said nothing at all that Jesus made me understand. She is not able to express
everything which is normal. But he gives her a vital answer and I want you to put VIP on
the next small bit. It's only two, three sentences. Then he added true sanctity is in doing. That
means living my will and in reordering all things in me. Now this reordering is all that
we have learned in the early volumes fighting the wars with the passions and the human stuff
and the this and that and the other reordering all things in me. Just as I keep everything
in order for the soul, so should the soul order all things for me and in me. So everything
is to be done through him, with him, in him, for him, for love of him. So May the 9th, 1912,
how we can consume ourselves in love. Now the message here, the summary of the 36 volumes,
divine will and love. So Jesus said, my daughter, if the will wants nothing but me, if the intellect
occupies itself with nothing but knowing me, if the memory remembers nothing other than
me, here they are, the three powers of the soul consumed in love. Now in all future texts,
they'll simply be called the powers of the soul, okay, intellect, memory and will. At
the same for the senses, if one speaks only about me, if she hears only what with regard
to me, if she enjoys only my things, if she works and walks only from me, if her heart
loves only me, if her desires desire only me, here it is the consummation of love in
her senses. So you can see that that is a sublime union with God, okay. My daughter,
love has a sweet enchantment and it renders the soul blind to all that is not love, making
her all eyes for all that is love. So God is love, love has to take over, our whole beings
have to be reordered in love in the divine will, that is if we are to be able to sustain
this spirituality, because this spirituality is divine love in divine will, that's what
it is. So if our lives are not being reordered into divine love, we're not in the right direction.
It's the same for her, oh yeah, therefore for one who loves whatever her will may encounter,
if it is love, she becomes all eyes, if not she becomes blind, stupid and doesn't understand
anything. The same for her tongue, if she has to speak about love, she feels many eyes
of light flow within her word and becomes eloquent, if not she begins to stand her ends
up dumb and so with all the rest. So he's talking about a contemplative soul being taken
over completely by divine will and divine love, so that everything is love, what you see,
what you hear, what you speak, what you think, what you feel, everything. That's a major
transformation, isn't it? It's almost 8.30, what do you want to do? Stop. Because we had
a lot of communication before we started. What do you want to do? You tell me. Do you want
to do one more? Okay, we'll do one more then. So again, the next one is about love and it's
made the 22nd 1912. True love is not subject to discontent. That needs to be underlined
in green, white and gold. Because it's our discontent that tells us, oh, whatever I have,
it's not true love if it has this discontent in it, okay? And I want to start by saying
a statement of John of the Cross where there is no love, put love, and you will find love.
That's John of the Cross where there is no love, put love, and you will find love. In
other words, you will find what you planted. Where there is no love, put love, and you
will find love. So Jesus said, my daughter, true love is not subject to discontent. Rather,
from the very discontent, it takes the opportunity to change them into most beautiful contentment
by virtue of love. That means something happens that I don't particularly like. So instead
of sitting with discontent about it, what do you do? In the divine will you transform
that into divine currency, and offer it in reparation, or love, or thanksgiving, or whatever.
So you turn what to somebody else would be negative into something positive. Is that
okay? Okay. Do you want me to give you an example? Okay, so here I am, I'm in a group
and somebody in the group gives me a proper snub. It happened recently, so that's why
it's topical. Okay. So instead of taking the hurt that pride will take, or the ego will
take, you know, somebody hasn't recognized me, or love me, or whatever, appreciated me.
Instead of that, you register it because you're alive, and you say, Lord, I want to put that
with all the times you were snubbed by the scribes and Pharisees and the leaders of Israel,
so that your merits go on to this. I haven't done it. And then I want to put it into your
divine will, and I offer it in reparation for all the cases where people are not loving
their neighbor or whatever. And you've turned it completely, and not only have you turned
it into something positive, you've turned it into real grace. And you offered, first
of all, for the person who snubbed you. How do I know that? Because Jesus actually died
for the people who were actually killing him. He died for their salvation, not just the
salvation of everybody, but the actual people who were killing him. So that's how in the
divine will, you change everything into something completely positive. If you feel the heart
too deeply, then throw yourself into your nothingness that really helps. It really helps. The
nothingness is really the safe place. But that's what he says that everything is transformed
and turned into divine currency. So more so since being content of contentment, I cannot
tolerate, notice the word tolerate, any discontent in the soul who loves me. He doesn't want
us to be discontented about anything or negative about anything or disturbed. As I myself feel
her discontent more than if it were my own rather than hers. And I am forced to give
her whatever thing renders her content in order to have her all conformed to me. Now,
if the Lord has to tell me at my age, you know, your grand, your grand, and give you
the rub down and everything. You're not very far on the road. You do that to two-year-olds,
don't you? And three-year-olds and you hope they grow up at some stage. Okay. So if we
expect the Lord to console us after everything, that tells us we're very far back. Otherwise,
he said, there would be some clashing and dissimilar fibers, heartbeats, and toads, which
would make us lose the best of our harmony. And I cannot tolerate all this in one who
truly loves me. Now, notice the reason why he doesn't want it is that love is total unity
and harmony. And he doesn't want that harmony spoiled. He hasn't got that kind of union with
too many people on the earth. So moreover, true love operates out of love. That means
your motive for doing whatever you're doing is love. Now, we learned from volume one to
volume four that the only real motivation he accepts from us trying to live the divine
will is love. And outside of love, it couldn't operate. It asks out of love and out of love
it surrenders. So love ends all in love and out of love it dies and out of love it rises
again. Okay. So everything is love. So let's come back to the fact that the snow began.
Okay. I receive it in love, transform it in love. Okay. The thing therefore turns into
love. You surrender. God has allowed this to happen to you. You surrender in love. So
all things are transformed into love. That that means that for every time you do that,
you have made your acceptable baggage this way to heaven bigger because love is the only
baggage you can actually take. And the more of it you take, the greater your heaven. And
so every opportunity, every small little thing that happens to us, if we learn how to transform
it into love. And if you have sorrowful or upset feelings, instantly throw them in with
the agony of Jesus and get seminy and turn it into love, turn it into something positive.
And once we learn how to keep transforming things into love, we're fine. That makes sense.
You don't succeed every time, but try and succeed more often than you did. And it helps
and, you know, and if you find that an opportunity came and you missed it, just say, Lord, I want
to say sorry for missing that and move on and don't give it any more thought because
any child who is learning, they don't get it all right all the time, do they? So we
don't get it right all the time either. So Louisa said, Jesus, it seems that you want
to escape me with all this talking. Look at the way she's completely herself. And what
you have to know that I'm not giving up, she said, for now you surrender to me out of
love. Do for me an act of love and surrender to that which is so necessary to me and to
which I am so bound. As for the rest, I surrender everything to you. Otherwise I will be discontent.
How about taking somebody literally? She's taken him literally. And she said, this time
you give in to me and love. Otherwise I'll be discontent. It's amazing. Absolutely. And
Jesus said to her, you want to win by dint of discontent and he smiled and he disappeared.
And he smiled because she took up so quickly what he was saying. And not only that, but
she used it against him. I find fascinating. Okay. So do you want to leave it there for
tonight? And we'll see you next week. God's help.